I'm afraid Gary
there is no foreseeable outcome where
you survived Wow
good morning Gary day 1818 how about
freaking know you are not the captain
you are a prisoner aboard this ship as
soon as the crap hit the interstellar
fan I became a captain for real you're
oblivious to this thing aren't you
what bet no cake what's a moon cake that
is a planet killer
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm not waiting while command sits
around twiddling our wieners why would
they be twiddling their wieners why as
long as I draw breath and you provide me
with copious amounts of adventure I will
be there for you we're a team now Gary
if the breach in time-space cannot be
reversed in 36 hours
the earth will be consumed you were
right about everything I know
it's a blessing it's dangerous it's
life-threatening
we're probably gonna die little buddy I
didn't really sell that very well did I
you know you can't succeed your lil hero
your followers
escape there's no winning this there's
no way to cause this breach of helpers
my friends
[Music]
are we going home dad I guess the best
but I'm not gonna leave you here I
promise I'll do whatever it takes
[Music]
what course should I send earth or
actually know the universe we're gonna
save the ratchet with that other they
make Dean ding sense okay just earth
earth earth
[Music]
you look it's Carl Carl how's life Carl
is dead
Gary classic Carl hey everybody olan
Rogers TV series is finally here it's
gonna be airing during TBS's new Adult
Swim style animation block Friday night
so I'll explain what the schedule is
going to be it's probably gonna be the
best replacement for Rick and Morty
while we wait for it to get here so if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
I will do a weekly giveaway for this
that I'll explain at the end of the
video but if you couldn't tell it's
almost like Rick and Morty had a baby
with space dandy and maybe some bozo
horsemen because they actually got a
couple of people that worked on those
shows to work on this in addition to
Conan O'Brien so Conan O'Brien was sort
of the person that helps Shepherd it
through their production company so
there's like this great pedigree with
this if you have no idea who olan Rogers
is he's actually been a YouTube creator
for a long time one of the YouTube
creators from like a long time ago that
slowly transitioned to traditional media
like that's actually a big thing now
people being discovered on YouTube and
getting TV shows of their own so in the
way that Justin roiland started out with
Rick and Morty by doing doc and Marty
there's actually a pilot version of this
that he did a number of years ago but
just didn't have the resources to do
more episodes he originally intended to
do it as a webseries but then you know
cuts it today and it's actually a
full-blown ten episode series there will
be ten episodes and if you couldn't tell
David Tennant is actually the voice of
the villain this is him talking a little
bit about him we definitely wanted our
bad guy which is played by David Tennant
to be like a real threat like yeah
somebody that you know when our good
guys actually go up against them they're
like man something's gonna happen you
know it's like Oh safe yeah yeah and so
we we want that everything about this
show is toned and there's so many
science fiction you know cartoons out
there that you know great ones
Futurama Rick and Morty love those yes
and there's our like kind of a
commentary on science fiction and this
is actually science fiction so in the
lines of like sunshine or interstellar
or
you know Star Wars it's like it's in
it's just that
so obviously that cast list is insane
you probably picked up on a couple of
the voices like Keith David is one of
the most identifiable voices ever so
they have the president from Rick and
Morty playing this giant space creature
some kind of alien
Guga has infested the kennedy sex
tunnels
I wanted hunted down and taken out
kennedy sex tunnels naturally you'll
forget you saw them along with in order
of national embarrassment the truman
cocaine lounge the McKinley hooker dump
and the Lincoln slave Coliseum so olan
rogers has been talking about the series
because people compared it to Rick a
morning he's like well it's not exactly
like Rick and Morty but you can tell the
characters are very different from that
but in the very high-minded high-concept
sci-fi way it's like Rick and Morty with
the notable exception that they deal
with time-travel instead of hopping to
different realities so like when Rick
and Morty Cronenberg the world or they
mess with squirrels they just go to a
different reality but in this series
when the hero bails there's a bit of a
time-travel scenario they call them time
worms so that's sort of their version of
Rick and Morty just packing up their
and going to a different reality
pack your that's only gonna keep
them down for a little bit Morty
you squirrels Morty we got a good five
minutes before they're backing up on our
ass Morty we have to pack up and move to
a new reality Morty you know we said we
could only do that a couple of times
we're over here
you save the universe
[Music]
mooncake here is sort of a MacGuffin of
the series he has this very anime like
Super Saiyan mode where he goes all
Death Star he's like a planet killer so
he's one of the things that David
Tennant the villain of the series is
trying to get so that he can use him as
a weapon while the heroes are also
exploring what they call final space the
edge of the universe that's what the
title is all about final space is
literally the edge of the known universe
so let me know what you guys think of
this so far because I do feel like it's
a good replacement for Rick and Morty
while we wait for season 4 to get here
if it ever does get here Adult Swim has
still not officially confirmed that it's
renewed rick and morty for season 4 even
though everybody knows that they're
going to do it it was literally the
highest-rated thing that Adult Swim has
ever done in the history of the network
of course they're gonna bring it back so
what'll happen is is I'll try to point
out Easter eggs as I do
episode videos for this but because it's
airing Friday nights at 10:30 p.m. my
videos for it will post Saturday morning
which is the same thing I did with Rick
and Morty because that air so late at
night you'll be able to watch it or
stream it pretty much everywhere else
you watch cable television series I
don't know if they're gonna simulcast it
on their website the way that Adult Swim
does that but we'll find out next week
but I think for the most part people
have access to TBS because it's a
relatively common cable channel so leave
all your bonus video requests in the
comments below I will do a weekly
giveaway for this but you guys can just
leave me your suggestions on what you
think that giveaway should be for I'll
announce a new winner when I post a new
video for this like there'll be more
trailers in episode 1 obviously drops
next month but congrats to olan rogers
youtuber who has risen above to become a
showrunner of his own big-time Hollywood
now so while you wait for everything
click here for my new Rick and Morty
trailer video and you can click here for
brand new black panther thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]